france région froid bienvenue en
province à châlons sur marne en
champagne bonsoir à tous et à toutes
et nous allons commencer par premier jeu
n'est ce pas monsieur bouin eric bouin
alors vous avez réalisé cet objet qu'on
appelle une fille violante
à quelle occasion et pourquoi voilà la
question que nous posons aux invités de
notre avis marc menant pourquoi cette
fine yolanthe fabriqués par monsieur
bouin
première question à vous trouver la
réponse non non c'est de la danse ou
stressés de menin est ce que c'est un
genre de gars au nom parce que ça sert à
frapper quelqu'un rouvrir un petit peu
après la frappe et ça fera un être
humain
oui oui a frappé à l'être humain c'est
une sorte de silly de deux cas elle se
fout et une quelque chose que les moines
se met pour sedan des pénitents sinon
c'est pour frapper à l'être humain
oui une femme donc pas une femme à
l'animal un homme
oui d'accord à 9 1% ils y tiennent une
femme aussi une femme ou un homme
richissime semblait hommes et femmes ou
hommes et ces femmes
ça n'a aucune importance si c'est
l'importance non c'est pour le punir non
plus c'est un ancien nom c'est un moyen
de torture pas du tout c'est tout à fait
ça ça on peut s'en servir maintenant on
se resserre encore bouboule frappait
pour le plaisir non marqué on ne sera
pas très fort en voudraient s médical
non plus on assiste là il ya des
connaisseurs non ce n'est pas pour le
plaisir on fera pas très fort s'est
posée je sais pas moi c'est pour que
pour faire circuler le sang à nos
frappes et on frappe après fort il faut
attacher
non faut pas la tâche aux frappes
seulement on fera pâle mais ça sert à ça
cessation des fonctions non ce n'est pas
pour la défense les sas mais ça
fonctionne comme pour frapper ou sait
rien de notre usage
c'est un usage symbolique un message
symbolique signale quand même que
patrick ou non il ya douze minutes enfin
il a sonné oui bah oui depuis que vous
savez qu éventuellement que cette fois
pour le plaisir
bon ben vous allez savoir monsieur pour
200 francs dit le coup alors éric bouin
à quelles raisons pourquoi avez vous
fabriquez donc cette fine yolanthe
expliquez nous alors je suis d'abord
élève à l'école nationale supérieure des
arts et métiers de châlons sur marne et
il y à une période d'initiation et cette
banalisation se termine au bout de deux
mois d'entrer à l'école et j'ai fabriqué
de mes mains cette violente qui sert à
fignoler la tenue que l'on a
le jour du baptême des premières années
voilà donc la réponse alors attendez
attendez on va maintenant vous le dire
qu'un hasard et en étant dépendant la
cérémonie je crois je pense savoir
carrément donné on frappe avec non voilà
pendant la cérémonie le signe du baptême
ça se rapproche un peu du glaive du
chevalier
avez vous nous faire une démonstration
la voilà on va voir un petit peu ce que
ça donne son championnat
alors attendez imaginons c'est le jour
de votre baptême cher monsieur c'est
mieux voilà regardez bien comme ceux-ci
intérim était vous un petit peu de
profil qu'on va bien le mouvement et
comment vous frapper alors allez-y à la
fête voir
dépêchons nous voilà il faut quelqu'un
qui soit genou donc en berne et à
l'egypte
regardez bien voilà voilà pourquoi on
frappe
attendez j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
ingénieur un jour alors allez-y
doucement à mon grand allez-y
voilà cette fine yolanthe pour nos
ingénieurs de l'école des arts et
métiers trois ans d'école et le diplôme
d'ingénieur
c'est une tradition qui est quasiment
centenaire puisque le centenaire sera
fêté à champs-sur-marne l'an prochain
merci messieurs on vous applaudit encore
une fois bravo